Hard stop at three.
And we're live, I guess, now. Surprise.
And normally, there's like a 54321.
Not when I'm the host.
Let's go. Let's do it live.
Oh, man.
Alright. Maybe I should check and see on my phone if there's a live stream there. It looks like we got it. Yo,
Tyler,
here here's the million dollar question. Are you ready? I'm ready.
Have you ever seen the movie Cool Runnings?
I know of it. I have not seen it. Fucking hate, man. This is crazy
to me.
You know of it, though? Am I too young?
Well,
I'm just kidding. I don't know. Yeah. I know of it. Day, we paid a nickel to go see Cool Runnings in the movie theater.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
The dude had his, like, lucky egg that he kept in his spandex.
Yes.
Oh, man.
So good. I'll write it down. Movie is a game changer.
Oh, man. Can probably catch it on the Hallmark Hallmark channel.
Yeah.
Dude, it's such a good such a good flick. Honestly, with your fiance,
highly recommend a Friday night. Alright.
It'll probably be all blurry and, like, wait. I gotta get this on a VHS. Do you know what a VHS is?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We had it back in the, the old Honda Odyssey, the family rig. Nice.
Yeah. Legit. The one with the screen, you know, the flip down screen for all the kids. Wait. It took VHS tapes in the car?
Oh, yeah. No.
Oh, yeah. Now you know Tyler's riches all get out. Lot of road trips.
Dude, no
way you had that. That's insane.
It's pretty awesome.
That was like my dream as a kid.
Yeah. My mom would recline so she could see the camera from the second row
or the the the screen.
Dude,
that's crazy. That's funny. That's awesome. Could you watch TV in there also?
No. But I would bring my,
PlayStation two. Let's fuck it up. Dude, we didn't even have baby seats in our cars when I was growing up.
You you guys had wheels? We Oh,
man. Well, hey, Tyler.
Welcome.
Now you're gonna be a mainstay on Pod 256 now. Go forward.
Rob Warren's out.
Yeah. It kicked that guy to the curb.
But, no, Rob's got
some exciting stuff on the horizon
and, or not even on the horizon. He's here now.
And,
but, no, Tyler, like, is a perfect addition. So seriously welcome. Thank you. For the folks that don't know you, Tyler, you wanna do a quick brief introduction?
Sure.
My name is Tyler. I
am very passionate
about bringing mining back home along with you, gents.
Trojan Horse does heating appliances and devices. So that's kind of my whole shtick. Hash rate heating, as we call it, heat punk movement.
I'm sure we'll talk about it throughout. But,
that's what I'm focused on is bringing mining back home. Wrote a book about it if you're curious to learn more. And there's lots of fun ways you can get engaged via forum or heat punk summit and bunch of stuff like that. And met you gents at the park in Nashville,
trying to attend a lot of those summits and conferences. Been awesome to get to know you guys better. So happy to be a part of this. Dude, tell everybody that crazy stat. And I wanna just
I I I know it's gonna be
pretty dumb, but I'm gonna do it every single, probably, podcast.
I want you to repeat this stat until everybody and their mom is repeating this stat. I must need a better way to, you know, deliver this stat because you can't really grasp it. But,
No. I'm rock tarted, man. I'm like, I'm down on the left side of the bell curve.
1%
of the air and water heating industry would bring the network to three Zeta Hash. It would add two Zeta Hash,
at 25 joules per terahash. So not even cutting edge efficiency, just like a blended average.
Repeat that one more time. Because we're at one zeta hash right now, roughly. Yeah.
Yeah. So the the heating market for air and water, which Bitcoin miners make,
is 250
times larger than all the energy used to mine. So if you tapped into 1% of the heating industry
with hash boards as the heating element, you would be at three zed a hash.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
This is why not to, like, chill your bag of what you're concentrating on with exergy with your guys
is just that market
seems like insane
opportunity. Insane.
Insane.
And I I think it's cool that it really shakes up the incentives of what the traditional miners are dealing with. You know, you go to these summits and conferences and we hang out and you hear their pain points. We were just at that proto launch and you hear a lot of the miners in the room. I struggle with this. I struggle with that. Hash price, automations,
maintenance,
service, techs. And I'm just like, dude, my,
my floors are heated with a Bitcoin miner. I don't have any of those problems. How many sats did I get today? Oh, I don't know. Like Yeah.
Yeah. Like and that's the other thing. Again, that's why I'm so bullish on this, and we're going on a bit of a tangent. And I wanna talk about the proto launch, and we can just riff on a bunch of stuff.
But
imagine if my HVAC guy was coming over and was like, dude,
I'm gonna make sure your stuff is running tip top shape.
Boss, you're gonna be
heated like none other. Blankets? You don't need blankets.
You're gonna be so hot in this in the winter that you're gonna be telling me, no. No. Cool it down. Cool it down. It's too hot. Too hot. Too hot. I know. I know. It would be awesome because it took me so long to just get our plumber to come back and, like, flip the valve around that he installed backwards. You know? It's, like, gonna be he's gonna make $200. He's got a bunch of other jobs, and he's like, I don't wanna come 10 to these guys. Or it's like a $100 call. Hey. So you gotta send me like, pay me a $100
just to get my time
to schedule me or $200.
And then when I show up, I don't know what the issue is, but it may be like a a thousand bucks. So be prepared.
Yeah.
Versus funny. Like, hey. I, you know, I wanna sit at home and lever utilize my proto fleet fork and just be messing around with my dashboard
and making sure everything is tip top shape. Oh, you know, fans messed up over at the space. Okay. Let me just go notify the guys and just say, hey. One of your fans is messed up. I'm gonna come proactively
replace that fan. Like,
what kind of customer service is that
in the new world? And that doesn't even have to, you know, be the Bitcoin angle. It's just like, that sounds like an awesome performance benefit. I want that. Yeah. Exactly. I want that. We were talking about this last week on the pod, the livestream, and I had a call yesterday.
A guy booked some time with me. He was like, I heard you guys livestreaming from the proto thing, and I already called, like, six HVAC companies in Western Massachusetts, and I just wanted to pick your brain.
That's awesome. What's he trying to do? Yeah. He he's got a duplex. So for a guy like him, he's like, wait a second. I can get my tenants to mine for me, and they won't even know it?
This is the way. Well, actually, you see the kind of alpha you get tuning into pod two fifty six?
Dude, I'm I'm tuning in finally to pod two fifty six. It just gave me some alpha, which is
thing about owning a
Finally.
The the the
the duplex,
imagine because it's gonna be super competitive on,
rates.
So you may offer incentives like, hey. Heating and cooling is included. Right? Mhmm. Part of your rent.
And before you're like, hey, man. Could you just please just chill out on the on the AC? They're not.
So whatever. If they're tuning it up, especially in Western Mass during the winter,
cranking it up Yeah. At least I'm earning sats. Rod's Oh, yeah. Gonna price gouge the Airbnb
market because it's gonna be 90 degrees
in in his
apartment. Hey. Rev Hoddle had that prototype of the the the cooling miner. Yeah. That's right. Dude, Rev Hoddle's the man. He is the man. It's like you can have it hot or you can have it cold, but whatever it is, it's gonna be to the max.
Or we're We've just put them both on. Yeah. Exactly. Oh, true.
Well,
alright. Well,
I we're gonna get do a tight forty two minute rip from here on out. Super excited. Dude, what what did you guys think about that proto launch, by the way? And, of course, eco in classic fan fashion's got a what's minor perfectly positioned right over his left shoulder. You know? Great product placement right there. But a good juxtaposition.
Send over a proto rig. I'll put one back here. Yeah. Seriously. Proto. Send us a rig. I'll I'll
just So let's talk and and we're gonna talk about all the the really cool things, and I think we did a good job of highlighting, like, all the exciting things. What were some like, some of the questions I have, like, what's the price?
Can Mhmm. Can we buy that? Like, you know, and I I we should've just followed up there. We probably would've gotten direct answers, but this is the the that that was one question I had. Like, what's the price?
Maybe we,
zoom out for just a minute and just talk about
the launch for anyone who missed it. Okay.
Go ahead, Rod. No. No. No. You go ahead. Dude, it was freaking awesome. Like, for for first of all,
massive congrats to the entire team. Like, straight up. It is so hard.
It it's hard to do hard things, and that is a hard thing what they built.
I mean, Perry,
Thomas,
Max, Jennia, Kaye,
like, I mean, Jack, all of them, the whole team,
you know, Jack saying, alright. You know what? I'm gonna give you guys the air coverage and the funding to go and experiment in this new area that we need to,
help,
compete in and not be, dependent on the Chinese manufacturers and sees it as a market opportunity.
Massive. You get a guy like Thomas to spearhead this while he's already got you know, he's been working on a number of different initiatives from Bitkey and so on. And now he's taking this on. And you got a guy like Max, same gig. And then you gotta bring recruit a guy for like, Perry. I think he came from Argo Blockchain. Was it, Scott?
Am I Yeah. Yeah. But he he's been involved in this for a long time. That's I, Yeah. It was pretty cool. I've been talking with Perry for a while now. He's he's a really good guy. But,
he he, like, called me up, like over a year ago and was like, I wanna, I wanna like run this new design by you that I'm thinking of for this like, this miner. It's gonna use like standard server style PSUs down below. It's gonna have this backplane. You're gonna be able to slot boards into it. Like,
the dude is is really on top of these things and and sort of the pain points I think that large miners are having. But, you know, he's been thinking about this for a long time. So it's really cool to see it come to fruition.
Well, and that's the other yeah. A 100%. And and then even just from the
Jenny and the team being and Kaye being kind enough to say, hey. Would you guys like to do,
you know, PODDivity six two nights? Which is just like, you you sure you want us versus, like,
you know, anyone else, but okay. Rock and roll.
It's cool. And that's the the other thing that was really interesting was
the team that was
from the other divisions. Like, all the people that were highlighted were, like, eight years, ten years, twelve years at,
Block now proto.
And,
it and that's one thing that Jack said. It was like, hey. You know, like, these are now all Bitcoiners. They were obviously not Bitcoiners before, but they now get the mission of Bitcoin.
And that thing is just it'll it'll be very cool to see
who purchases it and how it's used in market. Right? And the last thing I'll say, around this announcement was it was super cool to see Pubco Miners. Shout out to CleanSpark, Core, Riot, all of our friends there that were in attendance.
And it was really cool to see, like, the mid tier,
what do you call it? Like, wildcatter miners, like Cholla and, Wilson Mining.
And then it was like us.
So they kinda
hit the whole like, I mean, they could easily stay with the guys that are gonna spend the money with them, which is the pub chemist. That's who their enterprise market is, and rightfully so. But,
anyways, I I thought it was it was massive.
Huge achievement. The one thing I thought was funny, though, I thought about this on my way home, which is, like, super talented team that came from other successful products and projects. But in the same vein,
a team that talented, they probably looked at the Chinese competition. We're like, this is what we're up against.
That's a good point. Those things? Well
Okay. Expand on that then, Tyler.
Why do why do you think that?
I think one of the biggest takeaways for me was just the willingness to communicate and gather feedback from their customers and core users. Right? Which has been something that miners have been asking to do. Please take my feedback. Please be responsive and, like, can we get this tweak for years? Yeah. Dude. And so that was just very refreshing. It made set the bar pretty low for them. Yeah.
I know. And this is where I I do think or I hope competition is such a good thing
where
it'll
push,
you know, I you know, microBT is, I think, pretty solid. I think they're gonna innovate continue to innovate. I think and Bitnate and knock on wood. What as they see their market share decrease a bit, they're like, okay. Wait. We should listen to our customers. Wait. We should now
adopt these standards and so on because
we're we're losing market share. Mhmm.
We'll see.
It it was it was really neat to see them,
like,
doing this. Right? Making an an ASIC, the chip, is just
a really,
really just absurdly hard task.
I was I was listening to this podcast about the history of TSMC,
and they say that, like, modern ASICs are the most complicated things humans have ever made.
Like, the machines to make the machines to make these ASICs are just absurdly complicated. It takes
like,
you know, all the money in the world basically doesn't even get you a a good ASIC. And,
you know, you you have to have these connections at your foundry and the the allocation to be ready to take it in addition,
you know, to paying for it.
And so it's a big undertaking for a company like Block, especially in the light of of Bitmain being so far ahead. Like, they've been doing this for a while, and they make
absolutely
the most
advanced
performance,
chips that you can possibly get.
But yet there's still problems in this industry because Bitmain takes these really good chips, and they just throw them in this
garbage box and surround it with garbage firmware and, like, you know, just
screw you. Like, this is what you get. Yeah. And to see people going after those other inefficiencies in the whole mining stack and really try and attack those things and make, like, just a,
like, a cohesive mining stack that people can actually run. It's cool
to see people attacking that. And I really hope that,
they see some success because of this, and I think they will. But, you know, see that start to influence the industry
towards just, like,
these little crappy boxes
full of,
a lot of fancy chips.
I was really surprised there wasn't much talk at the product launch about the chip itself.
And I don't know if that was just because
they didn't see it necessary to, like, dive into real deep technical details, but
I was hoping to, like, at least see a hash board with, like, the heat sink removed or
get I know. I really wanted to pull that off. You and I were, like, trying to look in the side Yeah. You know, and count how many chips are in there, and then back out, you know, like, what's the hash rate of each chip? What's,
you know, like, how are we gonna how are we gonna deal with this, which was,
was fun to do. But,
to be honest, they're they're talking about 14.1
joules per t. Like, that's
that's behind.
That's behind a lot of what the sort of nameplate efficiency numbers are on the lattice the last gen miners. What are we looking at now? What's the the tip of the spear? Like, 12 jewels of Terahash?
Dude, the s 23, which is supposed to ship,
in January
26,
is listed at 9.5.
Oh, damn.
Yeah.
But here's the counter, right, to that, which is, alright, you're at 9.5 or you're at 12 or whatever.
The amount of breakage, amount of maintenance on those, you know, you're ripping and replacing a full miner potentially
versus
the and by the way, over time, that 14.1
knock on wood should come down. Right? Mhmm. And so what's your all in cost?
And I and those guys are, I mean, very smart.
They probably made a calculated bet to say, hey. We should go to market with this because the all in cost
of getting this in
with our lower maintenance
brings the efficiency
way up Right. And our return on our investment way up. Mhmm. And especially
the LTV, the lifetime value of it over time.
Right? Because if I'm a miner and I see, like, one row of these freaking bit mains like caput, and the amount of time to bring in a whole new box and a whole new thing. And by the way,
January 2026, just two more months, guys. Just two more months. And then it goes pushes and pushes and pushes. So I I think a lot of miners get get hung up on this. Right? They see the Bitmain website, and it says 9.5 joules per t. Right? And you're like, okay. I know my power price. Like Yeah. Multiply those together. I know how much this is gonna cost to run. Like, I'm gonna be profitable. Let's go. And then you build this, you know, multimillion dollar mine and reality sets in because there's more to it than that. Yeah. You have to look at the efficiency of the whole mine.
Yep. I wonder
just spacing out for a bit. I wonder if you're proto
to go and make a dent in the marketplace.
Right? You gotta do something
to go in because it's
it's a considered purchase
and you're replacing.
You gotta time the cycle right so that that the buyer is like, hey. I gotta buy new miners to replace those old ones. Or they're like, wow. You're giving me such a great deal. I'm gonna replace those and sell those
and then make a net positive or net equal, and I got my, an upgrade to my fleet.
I wonder if they would be in in the business of saying, okay. You know what? We'll we'll
give you these miners or we'll give them to you at, like, a very low rate. So and then we'll be in the upside as well, and we want, you know, 20%, 10% of the upside. Because you gotta do something creative. And with Bitcoin and Bitcoin mining,
it allows you to be creative. And especially with the right trusted partners too, because you could see the hash rate.
Totally. Or they can just cater to the underdogs that don't care about efficiency. That's me.
And I think they are. I mean Yeah. They are, I think, too. Yeah. We Yeah. We were invited to the event. Totally. That's a great start.
You know, we're talking with these guys about technical details. They've they've committed to providing,
chips, documentation,
open source
firmware management software. Like, the Proto Fleet,
management software works with other miners. Yeah. Works with other miners. Like, this is a this is a very, like, code Expand on that, Scott.
So Proto Fleet, for those who don't know, they announced was it's
it's some, like, fleet it's fleet management software. So you got a bunch of miners. Like, no one in their right mind goes to each miner and loads up the dashboard and, like, configures it. Right? If you have
more than
if you have more than zero miners, you wanna configure it through, like, one,
like, dashboard where you can see all the miners. You can, like,
see the performance. You can change it. You can schedule, like, curtailments,
you know, all sorts of things across your entire fleet because, like,
these things are
inaccessible
at best. So this fleet software does that. They gave us a demo of it. It looked very slick, like, well polished software. These guys have some experience doing that.
There's
there's there's cobbled together solutions to do this with existing miners. We've we've seen that from a bunch of different third parties. But
to be honest, the the Bitmain API, which is how software like this would interact with the miner itself, The BIM API is garbage. It's poorly documented.
It's not even really documented at all. I feel like the people that know how to use this have, like, reverse engineered this essentially. So
to see that, you know,
they're making minor management software
with I guess, we haven't seen it yet, so we're we're hoping here, but with a well documented API that people can actually integrate
into their systems to, like, make these machines work for them,
is gonna be hugely beneficial.
And, you know, since they're they've they've committed to, Fleet being open source, you know, you could modify that to control based on room temperature or all sorts of things there.
I think Fleet two,
it was such a slick demo. That was kind of why perhaps firmware wasn't mentioned.
I think they view that as the human machine interface is it's through the Fleet software. You should never have to go under the hood, the the bios, so to speak, in this example
of your laptop. Right? Like, how often do you do that? And it's the same with logging into a firmware GUI on a an IP address for a machine. Like,
why do that if all the API variables are there to control everything, manage everything, set everything up, automate everything from a nice user interface?
We we've seen this, obviously, on a much smaller scale, but with the BIDACs. Like, people have made all kinds of RAD management software
for your fleet of BIDACs.
All kinds of cool stuff, mobile apps, desktop apps,
ones that you can set up, you know, with scheduling. Some guy made this one and you can turn the whole, like, UI into this, like, acid trip kind of colors. It's but it's like people can just do this thing permissionless. They can just
try what they wanna try and I think that is going to unlock a lot of development in this space.
Heck yeah.
Yeah. It's gonna be it's gonna be really fun to see.
That's for sure. Iko, anything else that you had questions about or,
highlights from the the proto rig launch? Overall, I I just I thought the event was great. Like, the venue, the guest list, just the attention to detail, the food. They did a beef steak there for anyone who wasn't in attendance. It was just like
they just nailed it, like, 10 out of 10 on everything. And then in addition to that, like, the product itself was just awesome.
And, you know, I mentioned this on the live stream, but
I'll say it again here. It was
validating for me to see
some of the,
ideas that they were putting into practice with Rig,
because I saw those as aligned with some of the things that
some of the design choices we've been making with the two fifty six foundation, like the ember one being a standardized hash board
so that you can keep your enclosure, keep your control board, keep your fans,
and just swap out the hash boards as new iterations come along.
You know, that's something, Scott, you and I have been talking about for, like, a year now.
And,
like, to see
Proto do that, it tells me that where
our ideas are on the right track or at least aligned with,
you know, the same vision that Proto has,
even though the scale is is obviously completely different here
and,
the operations are completely different. But,
you know, it just
it it's affirming to me to to
it tells me we're on the right track, and we just gotta keep pushing forward. And there's like
I I was just talking with Ryan, the Mujina
developer, right before we jumped on this podcast and,
you know, he was expressing this, like,
you know, when when you see these events, sometimes you get these feelings of like, oh, man, we missed it or, like, they, like, you kinda feel like maybe they beat us to it in a way. But, you know, really, there's there's no scarcity of ideas here. Mhmm. And there's, like, no limitations to the different directions and use cases this stuff can get used in going forward. So
just encourage everybody to keep their foot on the gas and keep building.
Can't stop, won't stop. That's right. Number one, update.
Scott,
mi familia.
I was,
I was in in Latvia for Baltic Compact,
and then I, flew all the way across the world and, like, landed hot at the, proto event.
So, no You did get a Cybertruck
escort to the proto event. Did. Oh my gosh. That was so much fun.
Oh, yeah. You know, this event was, like, out in the middle of nowhere, Georgia. And since I was coming international,
my only option was to go to, the Atlanta Airport which is, like, over two hours
drive.
And, you know, I was kinda trying to figure out how I'm gonna get all the way over there. And,
you know,
friend of the friend of the podcast and and friend of the whole Bitcoin mining ecosystem,
Stephen DeLorme,
was like, oh yeah, I'll pick you up. And I was like, okay, cool. You know, and like, we didn't talk for several days and I'm now I'm standing out in front of the airport,
like, messaging him, like, yeah. Yeah. I'm here. Come pick me up. He's like, okay. Cool. I'm on my way.
And I'm just
I don't know what kind of car he drives.
You know Scott just thought Steve would just drive this beat up hoopty. Like, just like I was like Oh, no. I I was actually thinking in my head, you know, like,
you know, Honda Accord. Like, this is like
I mean, you know, whatever. It's just a normal kind of car. And then, actually, I mean, I'm standing there waiting. You know, tons of cars are coming by. He said he's on his way. And the Cybertruck pulls up and, you know, it's got, like, dark tinted windows and I don't even like like, okay. I'm just still waiting for for Steve to show up.
And then,
yeah, the window rolls down and he's in there. I'm like, oh my gosh, you're kidding me. So
we we rolled in in style. Thank you, Steven, for that. That was a lot of fun. I rented a Hellcat and drove from Atlanta, so that that was fun too.
That's pretty badass. It was a cool drive. It was, it was. Yeah. It's,
like rural South vibes all the way up. It was cool. What what's in the Hellcat? Is that the 6.7 Hemi?
Supercharged. Supercharged. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. An appropriate amount of horsepower, just 800.
That's just, like, bare minimum to move. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Cybertruck has it beat, but
sounds like you need that pick and place machine, Scott.
The what? The pick and place machine that Eco's got for the parts to build the Ember ones. You got a lot of work to do. I'm gonna have,
I'm gonna have Eco build them. Yeah. There you go. Dude, speaking of me which I got my ASIC chips.
Let's see. Let's see. Let's see.
Just despite all the the,
FUD on Twitter from the haters that said it's impossible to get bit main chips, I got
here's my reel of
Wow. Enough bit main chips to make a 100 ember ones.
Let's go. I posted some pictures on Twitter today. These things are I'm not sure people realize what an amazing thing that is to have. Right? These these are the bit main chips of which most people unsolder them from existing miners, which
is not a cool practice to see.
Like, those chips are not available normally. Yeah. How is this even possible? That that is a huge score right there.
Yeah. I mean,
everybody made it sound like it was this, like got a guy, by the way. I got a guy. Yeah. They made it sound like it was like this, like, pain in the ass process. And, like, I'm like, I need some chips. I wanna build these boards. I'm, like, combing through the bill of materials on number one,
you know, working with Sky, like, picking out all this equipment, getting everything set up. And
I'm like, dude, who am I gonna talk to for ASIC chips? And the first guy that popped in my head was Nick of MegaMiner,
formerly KaboomRacks.
And I'm like so I messaged Nick. I'm like, dude, can you get me
a reel of of these ASIC chips? And he's like, yeah. No problem. Like,
had a quote to me, like, the next day
and then, like, set up a Telegram chat chat with him and just, like, took it from there. And, yeah, easy peasy.
That's so wild. Where does he get him from?
I don't dude. He's got a guy. He's the dude. He goes got a guy. He's got a guy. His guy's got a guy.
So real quick, let's back up because
you you mentioned the bill of materials. Those are all publicly available also on our GitHub. Right, Eco? Yeah. And anybody can go and build these, by the way. Like, that's what's so cool about what the two d six is doing.
And, honestly,
a little bit of inspiration from a number of folks in in the space to be like,
Rod Eco. Like, Eco especially, just build this. Like and let's make it, and let's, bring this to reality. So it's really cool to see you're doing this, Hiko.
And,
and I I I think there's gonna be a lot of future collabs that'll be really cool because
there's so many ways you can go with this. Yeah. But I I I hope and I expect,
like, the Club Sources, the Solo Satoshis,
the,
a lot of the other ones. Go to the BitX,
legit list, and you can go see all those. Plus other lists probably out there now.
And, they're gonna be make knock on wood, they're gonna be making ember ones here in the near future.
Like Mhmm.
How how rad are Bitcoiners
and especially people in this space? Right? We're
like, we wanna start building some stuff. Yeah. And and now here's Eco sitting in the background. We can see he's got a pick and place machine.
He's got a reflow oven set up. Like,
we're getting shit done. This is awesome. Yeah.
It's kinda it's kinda nuts, to be honest with you.
And also,
kinda amazing.
Yeah.
You can just do things. Where there's risk, there's reward. Right?
Mhmm.
You can just do things is, like, the biggest understatement of the year.
Yeah.
I know, like, proto, they're just doing things. We're just doing things. I mean, like, it's it's what by the way, quadruple tangent,
I think I got somebody else lined up for the telehash in Nashville
in January,
and it's not a small miner. Oh, awesome.
For an exahash?
Exahash.
For
for 10 exahash,
Rod?
I don't know about 10, but
I think One day, Exergy will get you 10 exahash. Oh, yeah. Oh, you heard it here first. All the water heaters
on the Western Slope are just gonna be I don't know how to get away with that. Say sorry. We're stealing your water heater rewards for one day. No. You act as a well
well, you know that,
like, the invoice? You know how, like, on your or I don't even know, but, like, on your water bill, there's, like, a million different surcharges? Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You just add, like, another surcharges. Yeah. Two fifty six condition. Yeah.
But Yeah. What could go wrong? Yeah. What could go wrong?
So good.
Oh, man. But That's awesome. That was good. Yeah. You know, just just point a little point a little,
hash rate to us. But,
no. I I I I think we're we're tracking
across the board. Amber one, knock on wood, Scott. You're doing great job, man. And, you know, if you actually go to our website, we're we're teasing a couple other,
support.
Oops. Oops. What was
wait. Back up.
Yeah. Oh.
It's a nice square. Clip that.
Oh. Beautiful. This is the one I haven't finished yet.
Oh, shit.
Poor guy.
Oh, nice.
Yeah. That's
Oh, so That's the one that you do have one that's ready to test.
Or is that the v three?
I got so many circuit boards on my desk right now. This is madness. Hold up.
Okay.
There we go. That's the one. Okay. You should do a desk tour. Yeah. B four. Nice.
All the chips are on there,
recognized.
Yeah. It it works. I can, I can hit them all?
It's kinda neat with this design. You can,
not connect the main ASIC voltage so you don't need to run it with a heat sink on there. You can basically ping all the chips,
with just the IO voltage and check and make sure everything's working before you, like, squirt all the,
thermal compound on there and make a real mess and strap on the heat sink. But that's where this one's at. We got,
we got right here,
this is the, input,
over voltage protection circuit from Vamsta.
And I added I added the same thing on the,
the low voltage five volt input over here.
That's okay. Which we got on the output of the voltage regulator here too. It's nice and protected.
It should be Scott, you're the man, dude. So that's a big upgrade over v three. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. It you know, we we've talked about this before, but
v four was just gonna be a small little upgrade to v three. And then it was, like, oh, we can add some more stuff. We can add some more stuff. And then I was, like, alright. So I gotta prototype a couple before we just, like, go big and and crank out a bunch of these.
What's the
validation process look like from here on out? Like, you've got I know you got, like, this first sign of life out of the a six, but, like, is that it? Are you good? Or is there, like
I mean, surely, there's more testing.
The next step is actually the strap.
I'll,
oh gosh. Not that one.
I'll, I'll take the heat sink off this v three and fan and put it on the v four and then power up the,
you know, this part up here
is the high power, voltage regulator. So I'll power that up on v four,
do those tests. And I have a,
I have, like, a just a really hacky version
of Pmax's,
Piminer
Mhmm. That I modified to work with this. This is a cool, like, open source project done by the nerd QAX guy,
a while back. And it's
just it's just a simple little Python miner, and, we were using it during actually, during the last telehash. So it it works.
You know, it's like a command line thing, but it's just
need to have that from the community
so that I can, you know, have to start from scratch and,
contest to make sure that it works while Magina is getting, worked up.
Mhmm. But, we have,
Dwight is a, thermal engineer who's helping out on this, and he made a design for some heat sinks,
that'll go on there.
You know, because this this board is designed to be configurable, so you can use it in whatever configuration you want, you know, strapped to your water heater or just sitting on your desk. But for these first,
several devices that we're making, we wanna have it so that it at least works, you know, just on your desktop. So it's just kinda some some simple heat sinks that'll go on there so that people can use this for further developing, like, Magina,
the firmware.
So
Dwight finished those, and,
I think this one's gonna go to him
to, to test that out and so we can pull the trigger and get a few of those made.
And then the other one, once I get that other chip put on and,
get it tested out, this is gonna this one's gonna go to Ryan,
who's working on Regina so that he can,
make sure that his his,
BM1362
driver works with 12 chips because,
right now, I believe he's testing on BitX.
Mhmm.
Just just has one chip and isn't the thirteen sixty two. He's got a BitX,
and he's running that that raw that BitX raw firmware. Or,
Yeah. BitX raw. Yeah.
That was that was a cool project. Like, reached out to a a really, really smart guy in the community and we're like, hey. Can you make a firmware that just passes through all the data from the USB port on a BitX to the chip? He's like, oh, yeah. No problem. Banged it out real quick.
So we've got this alternate firmware for the BitX
that you can load onto your Bittaxe, and it just becomes like a USB miner, essentially.
So that now you can test it with, firmware running on your computer like
you would do with, a number one.
Yeah. So tentative plan,
Ryan's gonna get the prototype once Scott's
got it validated.
And then he's going
he's planning on releasing, like, a very early test version of Mujina
to go along with
this very small batch
of roughly a 100 Ember one boards that are gonna be made for the testers and developers.
So there's kinda like all these parts moving in tandem. So Ryan's working on the firmware,
Scott's
been validating the design, and then Dwight's working on that heat sink. So,
should be all coming together here pretty soon, and we're excited.
You wanna see some other cool stuff that's on my desk real quick? Yeah. Yes. Yeah.
This
is
eight,
Intel,
BZM two chips Oh, wow.
On a it's it's like two bit axes together. Like, it isn't like a final form factor at all, but it's the idea is to test a chain
of Intel chips.
Awesome.
I totally effed up the voltage regulator on this.
So I'm I'm in the process of hacking that
back into a working state so I can test on it. Oh. Pretty cool. What's the input voltage range?
It's like,
I think
to
Okay. Via this x t 30 connector. Okay. That's what we're switching all the bit access to.
But it's got this two phase voltage regulator here
to deliver the additional power for this.
Should be pretty cool.
There but wait. There's more.
This is Oh, shit.
This is what I've been working on, today.
This is the new bid x naja.
It is,
two
b m 13 forties out of the s 23.
Oh, wow. Woah.
This this bad boy, like,
I have plugged it in, and it it did not burst into flames, so that's a good first start.
But
this should be, like, normally, like, five terahash.
Holy smokes. Yeah. Yeah. I don't think this heat sink's gonna be adequate. So we got we got some work to do there. But
Damn. Really?
Yeah. Yeah. The these thirteen forty,
these are the big main chips.
They're big. Yeah. They're really big. I don't know if you guys are gonna be able to see this. But
Yeah. So, like, 50 watts. That is more.
That's like a normal sized ASIC,
and that Wow. Is the p m nineteen forty out of the s 23. Crazy.
Rumor has it, this is like the world's first two nanometer chip. It's impossible to tell, but rumor.
Why'd they scale up, do you think?
I I don't know. I mean, I think it's a power play. I think it gets considerably more expensive to do bigger. Because you can see this the shiny part, that's the actual dye. So it's it's quite a bit bigger
than,
than what's on that one.
Yeah.
But,
yeah. I mean,
doing bigger dye is, more expensive, more complicated.
Certainly,
you have,
you know, poor yield affects you
Totally. More, because it's more surface area of the wafer,
more costs.
But,
I don't know. Apparently, they decided that's what it takes to get
what's hopefully 9.5,
joules per t.
Wow. And then, of course, each chip, normally two and a half terra hash per chip. It's nuts.
You know, that said, like, those chips
are gonna be nearly impossible to get.
Except for you.
Well, I mean, I I, like, know a guy who know a guy who, like, found a couple of them that, like, fell off a truck or something. Like, it's insane.
Like, I'm not joking. I think they actually did, like, fall off a truck. The the,
hash boards that they're on are just, like, beat up. Like, I don't know what happened here.
Crazy. But, we got a really cool community, and,
a lot of people are really excited about this, making it happen. What the name Naja, what does that mean?
It's a kind of, COBRA, I believe. Okay. Cool. We've got a guy.
I've got a friend who has been involved in bid x development since the very beginning, and he names them all. Oh, cool.
Supra, Gamma, those are his names. So
I hit him up. I'm like, got a new
Bitmain,
Bitaxe coming. What should it be called? So nudge out. It's it's, yeah. It's a big snake. Awesome.
Are there any other, bit axes,
variants in in development you can share?
Well, I have one
that,
actually, what do I do with it? Oh, it's right over there. Hold on.
I'm just imagining, like, a pile all the way to the other side of the room
Basically. Of of boards.
This is the,
this is the latest revision,
the,
800 triple x
of
the,
BitX GT. So that's two b m 13 seventies. Oh, damn.
This one's And this keeps it's been in development for a while.
Should be pretty cool. Like, 12 volts got that same input voltage ring with the x t 30.
But this is this is a little bigger than your normal bit ax.
That's a normal bit ax. That's a little bit bigger.
Wild.
Yeah. The people people are getting ramped up on this one that should be
released soon for, you know, the community to to screw around with and build. Hell, yeah.
Well, gentlemen,
some closing thoughts.
We're gonna be back next week. Sorry. I no. No. No. Well, I I'm sorry. I have to roll here, and I gotta,
before this next call I gotta be on. But, I mean, you guys are more than welcome to keep ripping it. But, obviously, you guys love me and don't wanna jam without me. So It's true. I understand.
Tyler,
great addition. You're the better Rob. I'm just gonna call you Rob 28 from now on.
But Happy to be here.
Dude, Susie Scott, like,
God bless you. Thank you for being doing what you're doing, especially
we're still at the beginning of,
you know, this
dismantling the proprietary Bitcoin mining empire,
and you leading from the front and just doing cool stuff
is just massive. So I I cannot
give you enough attaboys and just thank you for all of the work you're doing, man. It's my pleasure. I love this stuff.
Iko, any other closing thoughts from your end? We're ready to make some miners.
Yeah.
Oh, I have good news for anyone. I sent out some emails. So
Hell, yeah. It's big it is
go on. I I sent some emails to those who are in the loop. But if if you're listening and you haven't checked your inbox yet,
I will be picking up the
Intel b z m two chips, the 256,000
chips that
Proto donated to the two fifty six foundation. I will be picking those up next week.
So we're gonna have,
I I've been talking with four
individuals
about,
donating chips to them for projects that they're working on.
So we're gonna be moving forward with that,
here very soon,
and I'm excited to share the details
of what these builders are working on,
in the near future with all of you.
Heck yes.
That's gonna be freaking exciting, man. This is so cool. These are like new chips on reels, which Yeah.
Is,
is is a real treat in this industry. Or I think these ones are on trays. But yeah. Bring me. No no no on soldering necessary.
So this is, you know, the beginning of a new era. And, you know, I hope we see Proto offering chips a la carte.
I I don't know if they will or not. I didn't get any sense for that at the product launch, but I hope that they do. They they have committed to that previously before the launch. So Okay. Good. We'll, we'll keep on them about it. Hell, yeah.
Awesome, gents.
Well, I appreciate you guys. We're gonna do this again next week?
Yeah. Let's do it.
Yeah. So I'll be prepared. I'll take over the host role, now that I know that. So I'll be Tyler, you do the prep doc because we gotta call out the Hashers,
and,
we'll get that going too. Alright. We have Hashers.
Yeah. Sorry. I don't have the the doc pulled up. We're gonna double it up next week. Okay.
Double state of the network? Double state of the network from last
it's a bonus one. Amazing.
Cool. Sweet. I'll see you guys. Alright. Take care. You wanna end this and then,
I gotta, like, stay on. Right?
So that it loads up. Yeah. Don't go anywhere.
Bye, everybody.
Later.